what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
delving deep into the life of media
toccata aka la million a member of the
big three and one of the strongest and
most noble hero students in the history
of UA
media is the always smiling friendly and
energetic mentee of sir Knight I and he
was the top candidate for becoming all
might successor before all might met
Deku meteo is also one of my favorite
characters in boku no hero he might even
be my absolute favorite if I'm being
honest and so in this video I will
explain exactly why media is such an
amazing character and why he is one of
my favorite tragic heroes in anime I say
tragic because media has led a difficult
life full of hardships and yet the way
that he has dealt with these hardships
made him who he is today media is a very
powerful and important character and he
is an inspiration to so many people both
inside the world of volcán o hero and in
our own world because let's face it
there are many important life lessons
that we as readers and viewers of boku
no hero can learn from media and that is
exactly what i will be talking about in
this video if you enjoyed the boku no
hero content here on the channel and you
want us to keep it going
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications seriously you have to
click the bell and turn on all
notifications if you want to see our
videos otherwise YouTube will just bury
them it's just the way it goes you can
also hit me up on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar for all the latest boku
no hero news and updates finally heads
up this video will contain manga
spoilers including some big spoilers but
if you just want to know about meteos
origins and quirk without additional
spoilers you can watch my video on the
big three and their quirks explained
link in the description however I got a
lot of requests in the comments to talk
about meteos life with spoilers so that
is what I'll be doing in this video
please proceed with caution
when we first meet media he appears to
be an overpowered mad lad who is always
smiling always positive and full of
energy as we learn more about media we
realized that he has an incredible
ability to remain positive and to keep
smiling even when he is facing the
toughest of challenges which is one of
the reasons why his mentor and former
sidekick of all might sir Knight I
believed that media should be the
successor of all might rather than bekku
but the more we learn about media the
more we realize what an impressive
person he truly is and how hard-working
dedicated and courageous he is even in
the face of impossible challenges back
when he was a child media fell into a
river and he was saved from drowning by
a pro hero this had a big impact on
media and along with the positive
example said by all might as the symbol
of peace media was inspired to become a
hero just like all might and the hero
who had saved him
but even though he decided to become a
hero at a very young age media had one
major challenge ahead of him medias
father explained to him that his quark
permeation was both extremely difficult
to master
and very dangerous to use this is
because if miryo made even the smallest
mistake while his quark is activated he
could be cut in two or have parts of his
body cut off from the rest of his body
his father presumably had a similar
quirk and he gave up on being a hero
because of how dangerous this type of
quark was but media refuses to give up
on his dream of becoming a hero he spent
many years working extremely hard in
order to learn to control his quark and
while he underwent this intense training
he faced many hardships and setbacks for
example he was often laughed at by other
students because he would get parts of
his body stuck inside objects that he
was trying to pass through or he would
become stuck upside down in the ground
or he would lose all his clothes and end
up completely nude in front of his
classmates if you ever bit to high
school or any school really you know how
hard everyone tries to fit in and how
difficult it can be to stand out and be
laughed at by everyone around
you but me do accepted all of this
because he was so determined to learn to
control his quirk eventually media did
manage to do the impossible and he
learned to control his quirk even though
he was an underachiever when he first
started attending UA
he was eventually taken under the care
of sir Knight I and he quickly became
one of the strongest and most successful
hero students in all of Japan he managed
to do this not because he was lucky to
be born with an overpowered quirk but
because he worked unbelievably hard and
risked his own safety on a daily basis
in order to learn to master a quirk that
was thought to be virtually impossible
to master even though miryo knew that as
one man he could not save everyone he
chose 'la million as his hero name so
they would be a constant reminder that
he wants to save at least a million
people this really emphasizes the level
of commitment that media has for helping
others and for serving the cause of
justice
another great indication of what kind of
person media is is his friendship with
another member of the big three Tamaki
ammaji ki tamaki was always a very shy
and nervous person and he had a hard
time coping with social situations back
when media and Tamaki attended middle
school together
Tamaki was having trouble using his
quirk because he was too nervous and he
didn't have the confidence to be a hero
media took it upon himself to cheer
Tamaki up and to help him gain the
confidence that he needs to master his
own quirk and become someone capable of
being an effective hero
even though Tamaki always had low
self-esteem and he thought only the
worst things about himself media saw
Tamaki differently
he believed that Tamaki was a nice and
kind person and he believed that Tamaki
had an incredibly cool and useful quirk
and it was thanks to media's
encouragement and support the Tamaki
learned to use his quirk and also became
one of the big three as a result of
media's incredible work ethic unshakable
positive attitude and endless courage
and energy and with the guidance of sir
9i media went from an underachiever with
a quirk that was almost impossible to
control - one of the best and strongest
hero students in all of Japan and he
also became the top contender for
becoming all might successor as the
next symbol of peace that alone tells us
so much about media as a character but
that is not the end of media story being
the disciplined and dedicated hero
student that he is media took
instructions very seriously and this
goes double for instructions given to
him directly by his mentor sir Knight I
so on the day that media and deku came
face to face with Overhaulin arey a
little girl that was clearly trying to
run away from overhaul meteos first
instinct was not to interfere because
sir Knight I instructed him to stay off
overhauls radar and that was so that
overhaul wouldn't realize that he was
the subject of a major police
investigation even though it was clear
that arey was in distress and that she
needed help
overhaul claimed that she was his
daughter and that she was just upset
because he scolded her which would be a
fairly normal interaction between a
parent and the child however there was
something clearly off about the whole
situation not least of which were the
bandages that were wrapped around ares
arms and legs bandages that clearly
implied that she was being mistreated
eventually arey willingly walked away
with overhaul and media and dec who
decided not to pursue the matter any
further which was in accordance with Sir
NIH's instructions but both medial and
Deku would later come to regret this
decision
they eventually realised that Eddie was
not over halls daughter instead she was
an experimental guinea pig for overhaul
in order to harness the incredible power
of her quark rewind overhaul tortured
arey again and again so that he could
extract her blood and then use that
blood for his cruel experiments when
they learned that failing to help Eddie
that day resulted in her suffering even
more under overhauls brutal treatment
both media and deku were deeply upset
and disappointed with themselves they
felt that they had failed to protect an
innocent child the very thing that Pro
heroes are expected to do and miryo
vowed to right this wrong and to rescue
Eddie from the clutches of overhaul once
and for all
during the raid on the Yakuza
headquarters media bravely battles
multiple members of the eight precepts
of death on his own
and his skills proved to be too much for
the vast majority of them eventually he
comes face-to-face with the leader of
the precepts overhaul along with some
other important members of the
organization including chrono stasis and
shin Nemoto even against such strong
opponents meteo still appears to have
the upper hand but eventually Sheehan
Emoto is able to use Eddy against media
knowing that if Airy was in danger media
wouldn't hesitate to put his own life on
the line to protect her Shin shoots a
quirk destroying bullet in the direction
of Airy media who could easily dodge the
bullet if it had been directed at him is
forced to place his own body in between
the bullet and aeri in order to protect
her this leads to media being hit by the
quirk destroying bullet and as a result
me do permanently loses the ability to
use his quirk but even though losing
their quirk would be enough to devastate
most people media does not let even
something as drastic as this affect him
he simply smiles at Eddie and tells her
that she will never be in pain again and
then he continues to fight against
overhaul without his quirk as a result
of his intense physical training
something he had to put himself through
in order to learn to control his
dangerous quirk meteo is able to fight
and hold his own against overhaul using
just his physical strength for five
whole minutes meteo takes a lot of hits
and he suffers a lot of injuries but he
keeps fighting against all odds
long enough for Deku sir tonight I and
others to arrive on the scene in a
last-ditch effort Media is able to carry
Airy to safety before losing
consciousness and collapsing in the arms
of his mentor sir Knight I meteos
ability to fight off multiple members of
the eight precepts on his own to hold
them off even after losing his quirk and
to rescue Aryan carry her to safety
against all odds simply defies all
expectations medius courage strength and
determination can truly be classified as
superhuman and the fact that he was able
to stand his ground against overhaul for
five whole minutes without a quirk shows
just how hard media trained in order to
learn to use his quirk in the first
place it wasn't his quirk that made him
so strong
it was his unmatched hard work and
determination that made me do who he is
today but now after all the years he
spent learning to control his quark
media finds himself tragically robbed of
the ability to ever use it again thanks
to being shot by the clerk destroying
bullet but since media chose to take the
bullet in order to protect arey
he has no regrets about what he did and
he bravely accepts the loss of his quark
unfortunately losing his quark was not
the only tragedy that befell media
during the attack on the Yakuza
headquarters after media loses
consciousness his mentor and friend sir
Knight I is mortally wounded by overhaul
as sir Knight I lies dying in the
hospital media visits him and speaks to
him one last time during their brief
conversation sir Knight I encourages me
do to keep going and keep pursuing his
dreams at night I tells me do that he
will one day become an outstanding hero
the death of sir Knight I is of course
devastating for me do sir Knight I was
one of the first people to recognize
meteos potential and meteos ability to
go from an underachiever to one of the
best hero students in Japan was in large
part to do to sir Knight i's guidance if
they were in medial shoes at this moment
most people would completely fall into
depression and despair in practically a
single day media lost his quark which he
had worked his whole life to master and
then he lost his mentor to whom he owed
so much but does me do give in to
sadness and despair on the contrary when
Deku visits me REO following the death
of sir Knight I me do is again his
normal upbeat and energetic self and he
is even doing physical exercises in
order to get even stronger even though
everyone would expect him to be sad
after losing his quark and his mentor
media knows that sir Knight I didn't
want him to be sad in fact sir Knight I
admired me do precisely because media
was able to keep smiling and stay
positive even when faced with the most
difficult challenges media also doesn't
want arey to be sad when she sees that
media is sad so he commits to being his
cheery self once again
despite everything that he just went
through when deku asks me do if he would
ever consider inheriting his quark one
for all now that he has lost his own
media says that he wouldn't because that
would make Dec who suffer as always
media is optimistic about life and about
the future and who knows maybe one day
after Ariel learns to control her quark
she will be able to rewind his body back
to a time when he had his own quark in
fact media is far more concerned about
the well-being of others including deku
and airy than he is about losing his
quark how many people do you know who
after facing so much hardship and
struggle and tragedy would still put a
smile on their face maintain a positive
outlook and put the well-being of others
ahead of just feeling sorry for
themselves when meteo takes Airy to the
school festival later on in the story
specifically in Chapter one eight two
and when he sees Airy finally smiling
and moving on with her life after the
trauma she had suffered under overhauls
control media is so happy that he
actually cries tears of joy this brief
scene says everything there is to be
said about media and what kind of person
he really is if you want to understand
the beauty and greatness of media just
look at the impact that his character
has had on other people look at how
meteos life affected the lives of Tamaki
Eddie and Deku among others media was
able to help them to motivate them and
to make them better people they all love
and respect media for that very reason
and as tragic as meteos life has been up
to this point perhaps the true title of
this video should have been the
inspirational life of media because that
is what media is an inspiration to all
of us if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see more videos like it please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications feel free to hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar I
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime upper patrons for supporting
our work and making videos like this one
possible special thank you to all of our
prohee
to your patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh baby rain nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson Kings eldress $30 beat
a garage Ian Anatole Cassatt's ki DJ
Nathaniel Alfa do and on he'll crucify
get our the one tear patrons the ones
who stand above all other clans
including Ingrid ah a lowland out of
Maddy Mac makoto-kun Seth Cooper and the
world and you know he's serious because
he didn't say so wild doll if you enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you please consider
becoming a patron even a single dollar
will give you access to our patron
exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]